hi everyone so we'll come to the
afternoon session
uh this app my name is Chen yuei I'm a
research fellow assignments and this
afternoon we will center around the
topic about learning under corruption so
uh many learning algorithms has the
summation that the samples are drawn IID
from the environment but this assumption
may not hold in the real world so we
want to design some robust algorithms
and such that it's such that it's robust
in a sense that if there's if there's
corruption in the environment the
performance of the algorithm can
smoothly degrade with the amount of
Corruptions and is this possible in the
learning problem we care about and we
will see the answers in today's talk
the first talk is by Hara padimata uh
was a DHT from Harvard University and
she is currently a research fellow at
Simon's
she will become an assistant professor
at mit's long School of Management next
year
her research focused on the intersection
of the radio computer science economics
and machine learning and it's especially
in incentive awareness incentive aware
machine learning and she will be talking
about corruption robots contextual
search today
thank you for the introduction thank you
so hello everyone I'm Hara to say my
name approximately correctly just forget
about the C in front of my name uh this
presentation will be uh I try to
basically combine some recent results
that we had with two uh great sets of
people uh Akshay krishnamurtis who is
one of our great organizers uh Rob
Shapiro Renato Pious lemon and John
Schneider uh and this talk is very
related to the things that we heard uh
heard from uh heard about uh from Elan
so I'll try to make connections but also
distinctions throughout the talk for
those of you who uh probably did not
attend the previous one
so let me start by uh explaining what is
exactly contextual search
and I'm going to start doing that not in
the corrupted version of the problem but
in the simpler the realizable version of
the problem uh this is not the setting
that I'm gonna be focusing on exactly
because I focus on the setting with
noise but this is the setting that has
existed in the literature uh and a lot
of bright people have worked on it so
contextual search is a fundamental
primitive of online learning uh where uh
there is an interaction that happened
happens over capital T rounds at the
beginning of each round nature chooses a
d dimensional context UT
um presents this context to the learner
the learner subsequently queries a
scalar Whitey
and nature replies with the sign of YT
minus u t dot Theta star which I'm gonna
call the target uh the target Point UT
dot Theta star
now what exactly is this Theta star
Theta star is a hidden Vector
multi-dimensional again who Remains the
Same across all rounds hence the
realizable version of our problem and
it's hidden from the learner
the learner subsequently incurs but does
not observe loss which uh depends on YT
which is the queried point uh and the
target point so the loss is correlated
between uh somehow correlates between
these two points what is different from
standard online learning settings that
you know and love
this part
so
in standard online learning settings we
usually every time that we query a point
we observe the loss of this point or we
observe the loss that was chosen for
this round
in contextual search we observe this
binary feedback basically only the sign
between the query point that we asked
for and the point that was the target
Point uh that nature had in mind
uh and for these settings contextual
search is a large contains a large
family of problems there are three loss
functions that we usually care about the
first one is called the Epsilon ball
loss and basically uh is one
every time that the difference between
YT which is the queried point minus the
target point is more than Epsilon
then it's the symmetric loss which is
essentially the absolute loss between y
t or queried point and our Target uh
Target point and the pricing loss which
uh is essentially the target queried
point that the target point I'm sorry
minus the query point if there was a
purchase and we say that the purchase
happens if YT is less than y t star
now we are going to be taking the
perspective of the learner who wants to
minimize the regret and we Define regret
as a difference between the total loss
incurred minus the total loss for a
benchmark querying policy
and uh aside from the theoretical
interest in these types of problems
these problems have been very
interesting also from a practical
standpoint and this is what also Elan
introduced to us uh in his previous
talks for example when we talk about
marketplaces like Airbnb the context UT
corresponds to the feature for the
features for a particular listing that
is listed then the scalar that we query
is essentially a price
nature who now is an agent that we
interact with replies whether they want
to purchase the apartment or the set for
the set price
and then this uh and then the learner
who is Airbnb in this case uh incurs a
loss but does not observe this loss
and similar examples we can we can have
for the personalized medicine case
so this setting has been uh well known
and uh the realizable version has been
studied extensively into zilan also told
us there have been a series of papers
trying to optimize for the different
loss functions that we have uh for this
problem and so I'd like to bring us all
on the same page and Survey a bit uh
pretty fast the results that we know uh
about this problem in the realizable
case Okay so no noise for now
so uh what we know is that for the
Epsilon ball loss there is a lower bound
of dealer one over Epsilon and basically
a matching up to constants and
logarithms uh upper bound of D log one
over Epsilon this is the best regret
that you can achieve
where the symmetric loss uh and this is
also what color is hinted in his
question to uh to Elan at the end of his
talk
um we can actually achieve uh lower
bounds of uh independent of T of the
time Horizon the lower bound is D and uh
there's a matching upper bound up to
constants D log d
uh to uh the next question this is only
we have only been able to obtain that
through standard Point uh arguments so
these require fundamentally different
techniques than the ones that I'm going
to talk about in this talk and Elan
mentioned in his talk
and for the pricing loss uh the lower
bound is D log log T and we can match
this up to a d log D bound so all this
is to say that even if you forget about
these exact founds this is a problem
that people care about a lot and they've
spent significant amount of effort and
time to optimize it
so what is a problem that I actually
want to study here
the problem that I actually want to
study is the problem where the target
point at each round YT star is perturbed
by a potentially a by potential
adversarial noise
so instead of just having the YT star be
the realizable thing that depends on
beauty therastarado rounds I'm going to
focus on the case that YT star is
perturbed by this ziti okay
and again you can imagine that in the
applications that we had in mind in two
slides ago now what does why what is the
motivation behind studying these types
of noise models well in the Airbnb
example they can correspond to agents
behaving arbitrarily and we don't know
we don't have any information about what
exactly is their behavioral model so we
want to model them as a worst case
adversary
and this is where the Corruptions
framework will come in handy
so what are the desiderata for our
algorithms now again remember we take
the perspective of the learner who wants
to learn even in face of these strategic
agents of these I'm sorry weird
arbitrary agents that uh they face so we
want two things we want one our regret
to degrade gracefully with C the number
of Corruptions or arbitrary agents that
we face and then we also want our
algorithms to be agnostic to see we want
to assume that we don't know C at all
I mean it would be weird to say that
Airbnb knows exactly how many arbitrary
agents are gonna show up to their
platform
and here are the main results that
hopefully I'm gonna outline in this talk
uh most of you if you were uh in the
audience for my job market have heard of
this result
um in more detail but I also wanted to
spend some time telling you about these
more recent results so what do we have
here uh as a result of our paper with
Akshay sudaris and Rob which appeared in
stock and recently was accepted in
operations research
we provide an algorithm for the Epsilon
ball loss with regret guarantee that
scales as Big O C naught DQ log Cube and
forget about C naught and C1 for now I'm
gonna tell you in a second what this
means
and this same algorithm with just a
small uh Small Change is able to achieve
uh uh regret guarantees of C naught D
cubed log T cubed for the symmetric and
the pricing launch
and in the very recent paper we take a
completely different approach
and from this completely different
approach we're able to disentangle the
corrupted term or the arbitrary terms
from the term that is achievable in the
realizable case so we achieve regret
guarantee Big O C naught plus d log 1
over Epsilon and symmetric loss which is
C1 plus d log T no results for pricing
laws so keep this in mind that's so
that's why like these methods here do
not dominate strictly with these methods
here
a comment on C naught and C1
um
so C naught will be the number of rounds
for which the noise is non-zero this is
the model that we introduced in the uh
paper with actually so there isn't Rob
basically C naught says that every time
that this ZT value is non-zero I count
it as a corrupted round
is this clear so it means that even if
you just use a ZT that's like 0.1 I'm
gonna count it as a corrupted round
and my bound will scale with the number
of corrupted rounds
C1 is a finer uh final control over the
Corruptions that is added that is added
to my system and C1 is essentially the
uh summation of the absolute uh noises
that is added to the system okay so if
at each round you added I don't know 0.1
of cities basically uh C1 ends up being
0.1 times capital T
if you were able to to put this in every
round
okay yes
IID from some unknown fixed distribution
excellent so if CT is uh fixed and comes
from a stock sorry the question was what
happens if CT is not adversarial and
comes from some distribution
so both the original papers on
realizability and Dylan has worked on
that setting so I don't take credit for
that do cover this case for the setting
where the variance is rather small so
you do have ZT uh here that is
stochastic but still like but then like
C naught might become large
oh the it's not these bounds so
basically yes exactly so you don't have
to go through that it's like lifting up
a bazooka to kill an ant like you won't
do that it's stochastic noise you can do
it much easier uh now when it comes to
this paper this paper can cover
simultaneously uh stochastic and
adversarial noise uh but again like it
has to be of a limited variance I'm
happy to discuss more afterwards once I
introduce the techniques
another question yes
okay so let's see how this talk will go
um let me just give you an idea of what
is going to follow here the plan is for
me to introduce to you
uh a little bit this algorithm here and
general idea behind this algorithm
to do that I'm gonna give you a hint
about what were the knowledge set based
or geometric techniques that also Ilan
hinted upon in the previous talk for the
realizable version of the problem
and then I'm gonna tell you why the
approach that we took in the cold 22
paper was fundamentally different and
I'll give you a snippet of uh the proof
that sorry that explains why this is so
different that he's able to disentangle
the terms uh C so the corrupted terms
and the stochastic
so the traditional approach for
contextual search algorithms and of
course uh here uh allow me to
um
to basically generalize among different
settings so I'm abstracting away from
them just so that I give you the general
idea there are various intricacies in
each of those settings that I'm not uh
covering right now so the traditional
approach is to say okay so for each
round as a learner I'm going to maintain
an active knowledge set with all the
feasible values from a Theta star what
does that mean it means that I know at
the knowledge set that I have maintained
Theta star lies in there but I don't
know where exactly it is
once I observe the context for this
round I will issue a query
which in the particular paper that I use
as an example here in Lance paper uh is
the inner product between UT and the
centroid of my knowledge set
and this will be my query point
and then I will eliminate the
inconsistent side of the knowledge set
what is the inconsistent sign if you
query this YT
the learner the agent will tell you that
hey Theta star is on this side
so I know that Theta star does not lie
on the red side and I will kill this
side for the next round
to do another iteration of this uh you
could you know see this context being
like that query this hyperplane and then
erase this part of your knowledge set as
inconsistent and so on so forth
now what does it mean to choose uh YT to
make enough progress
we want to choose YT in a way that uh
kills enough kills fast enough enough
kills fast enough enough volume of the
knowledge set so that we end up in a few
rounds having a knowledge here that's
concentrated around the truth data star
so it's like a potential function
argument
so the reason why you can achieve these
like regret bounds in the realizable
case of D log t
because introducing these aggressive
Cuts where you kill a product like a
constant function of your knowledge set
at each round is very fast and it can
help you achieve logarithms and again I
want to point out that there are two
important properties that our Cuts have
in this knowledge head-based techniques
that we should keep in mind the first is
that they never get to eliminate Theta
star which is by definition like this is
a realizable setting every time that you
query something I will always report the
correct sign
and then the second thing is this
potential uh based argument that I
highlighted this doing volumetric
progress by cutting through uh the
century
any questions so far
okay
and this this is the volumetric progress
like do you actually explicitly consider
a potential function that's like the
volume right so the question was whether
uh uh at the back end of the group it's
actually a potential
okay yeah it is
to explain
yes would the algorithm change at all
depending on the loss sorry I didn't
hear you
Advance if you change the algorithm or
is it and if I knew whether the laws
what do you mean by that if I knew the
loss of the varied point I know if you
maybe if you do the small ball or the
absolute value loss okay that's a good
question so the the question was would
the algorithm change if I knew a priori
which loss uh I'm facing and the answer
is yes so if you know that you're that
you're gonna face uh that you care about
the symmetric the pricing loss for
example basically the argument changes
slightly that it says that when your
knowledge set is small enough
now you should start essentially
exploiting the knowledge system so you
should query at the very end of the
knowledge so that you can always
guarantee a purchase those like slide
changes and similarly for the
symmetricals instead of targeting an
Epsilon big knowledge set we target an
Epsilon equals one over T big powers
smooth tweaks at the end of year
so what are we going to do now the first
order of business is to think about how
we can robustify this knowledge
set-based techniques
and if you were at uh so Theresa's uh
talk at the boot camp he basically gave
a very nice uh recipe for dealing with
these problems with Corruptions and his
recipe was roughly The Following start
from an algorithm that you can solve for
the non-corrupted case
robustify this algorithm for a known
corruption
and then apply multi-layering this
maintaining parallel layers in order to
jump from the unknown corrupt from the
non-corruption I'm sorry to the unknown
corruption
I'm gonna do something similar here
actually exactly that so I'm gonna
create a robust version of the knowledge
set based uh algorithm that I vaguely
hand waved to you in the previous slide
and then somehow run a variant of the
multi-layering grace technique
now I'm happy to discuss more about this
technique but uh the technical
difficulty in translating the realizable
to the corrupted version of the problem
lies in this part creating a robust
version of the original algorithm so I
will focus on this part but I'm happy to
take questions or afterwards chat about
the layer increase too
so
before I go and present what we did and
why this is nice and awesome I wanted to
take a minute and think about if we were
playing like a simple binary search game
okay you had in mind the number I kept
issuing queries about this number and
you would reply yes or the the number
that I queried was larger or smaller
than the number that you had in mind
if we played this game and I knew that
you have a budget of I don't know five
corrupted rounds
this useless thing for me
would be to just ask every question six
times actually 11 times
right because once if time doesn't
constrain me
once I get the response from you for six
times that hey the number that you
queried is smaller than the number that
I have in mind I know that your budget
for Corruptions is over so I know that
by default you've given me a non-crafted
answer and I can fall back to the
original setting like to how you can
solve standard binary search with
non-corrupted agents
so if we squint I'm going to try to do
the the same thing in the contextual
version of the problem I'm gonna try at
each round to query
the same thing multiple times to force
the agent to give me feedback that will
be valuable for me and there is no I'm
sorry non-corrupt
now there are various difficulties in
doing that and here's what we're gonna
go through here
so the first challenge that we face is
that in the contextual version of the
problem because the contexts are chosen
by Nature I cannot repeat the same query
to see this pictorially remember that I
told you that at every round the round
starts by Nature choosing a context and
based on this context I compute my query
point
so what am I going to do is I'm going to
give a penalty for each parameter in the
knowledge set space
and I'm going to introduce a hyperplane
cut
only wants a context cut which is just a
cut that's perpendicular to the context
retains the protected region on one side
and this is a mouthful
so let's parse this one by one what does
it mean to keep a penalty for each
parameter it means that if at some round
the agent's feedback says that hey you
should go that way
then I end up increasing the panel to
here
simple like the thing that you would do
in the binary binary binary search case
what does it mean to have a protected
region well a protected region is a set
of parameters in the knowledge set space
that all of them have less than c bar
Corruptions or penalties
so let's summarize I have assumed now a
known c bar because this is what I want
to do I want to robustify my algorithm
to a known corruption
and for this non-corruption I try to
build a set of parameters from my
knowledge set that all of them suffer
less than c bar Corruptions
I had a picture for that too
um so the Second Challenge is that
unless you are more careful with the
queries that you should ask
it may be the case that you never have a
context cut where the protected region
is fully on one side remember contexts
are chosen by Nature so if nature wants
to be truly adversarial with you they
will keep issuing hyperplanes that don't
allow you to form a good convex set so
that you can cut away and continue with
your hyperplane like your volumetric
problems
so the second idea is to somehow combine
the contexts that we see from nature to
compute a valid cut
and what is a valid cut a valid cut is a
cut that never eliminates Theta star
which means that it retains the
protected region on one side
and it has volumetric progress
which means that I somehow make sure to
cut close to the centroid
so that I can guarantee that my
knowledge set diminishes as the original
methods used to do
another question here or a better said
an appropriate question is okay horror
contexts are still chosen by Nature how
can I guarantee that such a valid pet
exists in a fixed set of time steps and
this is what we proved in The Next Step
which is that
choose the context however you want them
however you want I'll return
after 2D D plus one c bar rounds roughly
currency of dory's theorem tells us that
there exists a cut
that protects this region of points
let me just give you the pictorial idea
of that let's assume that at some point
this is the knowledge that we are and
this is the Theta star that uh where it
lies we don't know where Theta star lies
but I know that this is the area where
the penalties at most c bar
now car Theodore's theorem says that any
point
in the convex Hall
of the original area
any point here
can be written
as at most D plus one point
from
the from the set for for which we take
the convex call and of course I know
that I'm in two Dimensions so this D
plus one points in reality were two so
for this point here it should be here
and here but I just had it for the sake
of Institution
so what does that mean this means that
every time that you get a penalty point
there's a hyperplane that separates that
has this black point on one side and the
Green Point the Theta star on the other
side so it adds a penalty point to uh
the Black Point
basically this penalty can be attributed
to at least one protected point one
point from this red set here
and basically this means that the
penalty for the black points is at most
c Bar times D plus one
now this is nice because
what it would do
we started from an original set that we
didn't know anything about
we created this penalty penalty
parameters for you know identifying
which points are the ones that I can
kill safely
and now from this set I basically have
like a convex set of parameters that I
know exactly how to distance them from
others
so if I manage to find a point with a
penalty strictly greater than that I'm
done
I have this point that is for sure
outside the convex hall because every
point in the convex Hull has like a
bounded number of penalties and then I
have my convicts home so I can just have
a separating Point separate separation
uh hyperplane in between them and we do
that through a variant of perceptron to
find a valid cut
sorry uh roughly these are the ideas
that go into and of course I know that I
was hand waving a lot but these are the
ideas that go into uh robustifying the
original algorithm to
um to Corruptions
and after that basically you have the
um uh the multi-layering the
multi-layering grace which can give you
the transition from a known c bar to an
unknown C and at this point I'm gonna
stop for a couple of minutes take any
questions you may have
and if we're all happy I'm gonna
transition into telling you about the
new techniques that we have for this
problem
yes
we also satisfy property too that we
want
yeah that's an excellent question so the
question that you're asked is what is
the intuition that the valid cut here
um uh satisfied property number two
which I carefully hid under the rod but
I guess you've covered me
um in reality we have to make sure that
the points that we choose here are close
enough to the centroid
and not only that but we specifically
create
we put a set of anchor points around uh
around the centroid so that we can
guarantee that once you cut this
particular point from the convex Hull
for sure you're close enough to the
century but basically we have to we have
to care about that we guard rail the
centroid so that once you identify this
green point to be there the cut is for
sure cutting in the right place
excellent question
yes
okay
so
even if you forgot about everything I
told you about right now
you can still watch these last like 10
or 15 minutes of the presentation which
will tell you about a fundamental with
different approach to solving these
types of problems
so instead of playing with convex sets
and making these aggressive cuts
I want to argue and this is this may not
be a surprise to you but it was a
surprise to us and people that worked in
the area before
if you maintain a carefully crafted
probability density function
then this can still work well
so how would you maintain this
probability density function basically
the density at each point corresponds to
the extent to which X is consistent with
Theta star
and instead of removing values from your
consideration you just shift the weight
from more improbable to more probable
values
and just a pictorial representation if
we are in 1D and we start with a uniform
density uh over zero to one and Theta
star lies somewhere here then maybe
after a couple of rounds uh it's not
that you eliminate part of this zero one
space you just start shifting more and
more weight around Theta star and then
at some point you end up having a
distribution that's essentially uh uh
concentrated around Theta star
and the surprising thing is that
this is a clearly more forgiving
approach
but it can achieve faster bounds for
corruption uh corruption robust
contextual search
and I'd like to point out that
so what is the difference from these
approaches between these approaches and
standard multiplicative weights
we don't observe the laws
so that's the hardness that we don't
have we didn't have prior to this cold
paper we didn't have a good way of
maintaining these probability density
functions
foreign
that achieves the optimal Bound for the
Epsilon ball loss uh it essentially
matches the lower bounds that we have
for this case
and it achieves uh also a good Bound for
the uh symmetric loss but for the
optimal Bound for the nearly optimal
Bound for the symmetric loss we have a
different algorithm
so this algorithm is called the Epsilon
window median
and here's how it's going to work
basically the intuition is exactly as I
said before keep this in mind I somehow
want to maintain a probability density
function that shifts weight towards
Theta star according to the context that
I receive
so I'm going to start by initializing my
distribution to be the uniform in the
bowl zero to one Center dot zero and
having a radius of one
now at each round
for The observed context UT I will query
a quantity that I call the Epsilon
window median of the density ft and let
me Define this Epsilon window window
median quantity
note that for every UT
okay fix your team your head
X
is drawn from the distribution ft of x
so this means that this quantity here is
a random variable
it's essentially a projected random
variable
so Alpha
can be viewed as a projected random
variable on the rails
okay
so what is the absolute window median
the Epsilon window median is the YT it's
The Intercept essentially this Alpha
that uh we have before
that if you take an interval of Epsilon
around it
the volume of the density uh below YT
minus Epsilon over two
is exactly equal to the volume of the
density Plus at YT plus Epsilon over two
okay so if you think about it in a
one-dimensional setting it basically
says that okay if you have like a a
setting in one dimension you know all of
us know how to define the median
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create a padding around it
so this padding it will become clear in
a second why this is important
basically we do that through a
projection so that we can account for
for the context
and basically the way that we now update
the densities as follows if
we so according to the sigma T which is
the feedback that we receive from the
agent
for all the points that belong in the
knowledge set so B uh zero one for all
the points that are outside of this
Epsilon window
I increase their volume their weight by
three three halves
and for all the points that disagree
with Sigma t i lower their weight by one
half
so if you squint what am I trying to do
I'm trying to create a version of a
multiplicative weights update algorithm
that works for binary feedback
so what am I doing again
I protect this region here I say that
this region will not change the weight
but all the points that are above this
Epsilon over two
and they agree with my Sigma
they're gonna up their weight and for
all the others I'm going to lower the
weight
and so one can say well para what if you
have corrupted rounds if you have
corrupted rounds you end up lowering the
weight of your Theta star isn't that
problematic we'll know that this only
can happen c not times C naught being
the number of rounds that I have any
corruption
so this is roughly uh the algorithm that
achieves the C naught plus d log 1 over
Epsilon and in fact I see some heads
nodding
it's I think it's once you you you
understand how the algorithm works the
proof idea is crystal clear for anyone
who has a potential function arguments
it just says that
I have made sure that this is a density
from the weight that I play around with
these weights
okay
I Define a potential function that has
to do with the weight or the probability
mass that I have accumulated around
Theta star
despite not knowing where Theta star
exactly is and then all I'm saying is
that this potential either weekly
increases or it decreases by a half in C
naught rounds
in some sense we found a way
to create a multiplicative weight type
algorithm for band for binary feedback
and so going back to a question that we
had before about how these algorithms
change how these techniques change if
you have different loss functions well
this is the the guarantee that you get
for the Epsilon ball loss as is
customary in this literature
um if you set Epsilon to be 1 over T you
get for free asymmetric loss bound of C
naught plus d log t
foreign
time is T to the D and uh polynomial in
the dimension and the time
yes
the binary feedback how to distinguish
between being in the cartridge and
outside of that
so when you see the sigma
I don't distinguish I don't distinguish
from the garden I'm saying that the
binary paper is here all I'm saying is
that since I have projected this I'm
only gonna update things that are above
Epsilon over two
so basically my question is how would
you know that the theater is above
Epsilon number two
yeah
but
but you're you're only weekly increasing
this in this case
it's not about Epsilon over two then you
don't change the weight
so you're okay it means that you have
converged
so your point is that the round point is
what what if I start querying points
that are really close to Theta star
the absolute low loss treatment for
these points are zero loss
because they have most less than Epsilon
so you can continue querying the same
point it's fine
this metric loss treats them as adding
loss one over T because you've said
excellent to be one over t
and so that's why you don't care if at
some point you end up converging
somewhere here and this region here is
around that point you're good you can
stay and never change anything
yes so like the one-dimensional
uncorrupted version of this I've seen in
Fairbank is like the carb kleinberg
noisy binary search I've definitely seen
this like uh approach before has it
been General is like in a non-corrupted
setting to high Dimensions before yeah
so the question is uh connections
basically with a noisy binary uh binary
search yeah this kind of idea exists but
it was like for a much simpler problem I
was wondering so if it had not existed
for contextual versions and in the first
paper that we had in this area was
Solaris and actually and Rob we have we
basically have like a an extensive
description of what are the exact
changes between the settings and higher
Dimensions there are some other changes
that have to do with whether you want
you count every query that you issue to
the algorithm or only the queries that
are more than Epsilon away from your
target point so there are some
intricacies
questions
I know I have only four minutes but I'll
be done
so
very briefly
I claim that I have a polynomial time
algorithm for the symmetric loss
which basically apart from being
polynomial time
it uh it scales a C1 which is a finer
control over the Corruptions
so how did we get that
well the idea is again surprise surprise
to maintain a structured density
function at team
but now I'm going to be slightly smarter
about this density function and I'm
going to try to make sure that it's
logged on K
and why do I obsess about log concavity
I obsess about this because we know that
you can efficiently sample log concave
distributions which was the main
bottleneck that gave me the T to the D
rounding time algorithm in the previous
slide
now instead of querying this Epsilon
window median I'm again slightly more
careful and I query the centroid of the
distribution
I update in a way that basically changes
proportionately to how close I was to
the point
so in the previous algorithm what we did
is we said okay are you agreeing with
Sigma T yes you get a bump that is
constant do you not agree with Sigma T
you get a lowering that is constant now
I'm doing a finer control I'm saying
that
I'm gonna change your probability uh
according to how far away you were from
the centroid of the distribution
and roughly this is the algorithm uh
that can give you the C1 plus d low T
again it's like potential based
arguments
but uh you have to be a little bit more
careful with uh how the C1 appears
so in the interest of time I want to
summarize uh what I talked about I hope
I gave you some ideas about how you can
tackle corruption robust contextual
search
um the two algorithms that I mentioned
in the end that depend on this like
density arguments achieve regret of C
naught plus d log 1 over Epsilon and C1
plus d log t for the symmetric loss but
uh for reasons that we can discuss
afterwards they do not know at least
right now they do not work at least
right now for the pricing launch
which means that uh if every time this
is somehow similar to the discussion
that we had with Brad like if at some
point I'm I start querying Epsilon close
to Theta star I have to know which side
of theta star I am on
so for the rest of the audience that are
not familiar with this type of research
this is because if there's a single
dimensional case there's a price of 0.8
that you that this is where you should
you should be querying
it's very different whether you query at
0.8 minus Epsilon and 0.8 plus Epsilon
because 0.8 plus Epsilon means that the
person would not buy
but if you query a 0.8 minus Epsilon the
person buys and you only get regret of
Epsilon
so this is like the big picture why we
don't know whether it works for pricing
loss there are several open questions
here
well one that I have heavily hinted on
uh the other one is
for symmetric loss remember that the
optimal bound
in the uh realizable version of the
problem was D log d
so I want to see if we can achieve this
C1 plus d log d
and of course it's unclear whether for
the corrupted version of the problem we
can have polynomial time algorithms for
the Epsilon ball loss
and with that I will thank you all for
being a great audience and I'll take any
questions
[Applause]
why can't you use
everything that managed to get the holy
algorithm that is
we could not create a proper love to
take this
because the what is the intuition behind
Now situation is that in the actual ball
loss there was no concrete way basically
every Point that's more than Epsilon
away from Theta star this judge does the
same
but this method loss offers a finer
control it says that flow you can be
outside but you know it's not too bad if
your Epsilon plus Epsilon it's very bad
if your X is
is my understanding correct that rather
than keeping track of the distribution
you keep track of a sampling device that
you can sample from so the reason that
you have this log concave is because of
that yes exactly and then you take
samples in order to update the
distribution yes I see
um
uh you assume that adversary an Adaptive
adversary can you do better
we don't so as I said in the work that
we have with Solaris the previous one uh
we interpret not interpolate we can
handle simultaneously non-adaptive
adversaries and a doctoral percentage
um but still this is for like a small
variance which amounts uh I in this work
we haven't handled any uh stochastic
person
yeah so you you come sorry
oh sorry sorry that's the time so we oh
okay
thank you thank you
[Applause]